fares rodin hello Evan and Eric how do i
promote my business with newsletters how
should I come up with daily or weekly
email ideas for my clients yeah it all
goes back to the content it all goes
back to you know what is the business
what problem are you solving with your
business or your service in terms of
like we the--and monthly the first
question i would ask is do does your
audience even want daily messages do
they want weekly messages so let's
assume that they do you know courses are
a great way to you know satisfy somebody
who wants that information on a daily
basis so whatever your product or your
service is is how do you chunk that out
to like here are six tips and then
there's one tip per day and I would most
likely test that over the course of a
couple of weeks to see what kind of
response you get because some people may
think they want daily and then realize
that you know every other day every
third day is probably better for them so
tips is great for daily for weekly um it
all goes back to the tip what you're
saying Ivan about value so what is it
about your space whether it's you know
right now this time of year the future
of and kind of trends for next year are
important in every pretty much every
landscape or every business so you know
you know Tommy to right now you know you
know holiday is important of course but
you know give more kind of prophetic
statements on where you see your
specific product or service going and
that can serve as a nice weekly check
point and quite frankly even monthly as
well you can definitely over email your
client base um I think back to you know
groupon when a Groupon came out
everybody was excited about groupon and
then now you get a Groupon email and
like do you even read it anymore it's
just been like just too much is too many
emails um more important than the
quantity those going to be the quality
right to Eric's point it's got to add
value people will read it if it's adding
meaningful value to their lives if I was
doing a daily thing I would probably
have something super short and something
kind of inspirational motivational kind
of start your day with this quote or tip
right now I
post to my audience twice a week I'll
usually do a regular broadcast
newsletter that goes out every Wednesday
morning I tested that wednesday morning
at 5am seems to have the highest open
rates on my email list so that's when I
post my newsletter and then i do my
ongoing series the auto responders every
week from when they signed up so
somebody signs up but sunday at 3am
they're going to keep getting emails at
sunday at three and because that's when
they're likely to be online